here we go here's the speaker following
the meeting of the accession council and
the principal Proclamation early today
I'll first take the oath to his
Manchester time constraints me in the
small number of honorable members are
able to take the oath and make the
affirmation today those members have
already been contacted by my office
there will be further opportunities for
all honorable members to take the oath
or make the affirmation following her
late Majesty's funeral there is no
procedural requirement to do so
once we have concluded our tributes at
approximately 10 pm a humble address to
his majesty will be moved forward in the
terms set out on the order paper I will
now take the oath of Allegiance before
inviting other vulnerable members to do
so
I swear by almighty God that I will be
faithful and bear True Religions to his
majesty King Charles his house and
successors according to law shall be God
so sir Lindsay Hoyle is the first to
probably be the Prime Minister now it
looks as though sir Lindsay is going to
sign the book which is what normally
happens after a general election uh
there we go we've seen a lot of uh
senior privy councilors uh signing uh
over at St James's Palace early today so
that this this shows what's going to
happen uh it's uh the speaker has been
the first to uh swear Allegiance you can
see there behind the clerk members of
the cabinet you can see uh uh they go
from left to right Chris Heaton Harris
Jacob Reese mogg there uh there is the
uh PM I imagine the Prime Minister will
be next so speaker has uh got this
underway
could I you know begin to start with
father of the house so Peter bottomly
so it's the father of the house sir
Peter bottomley not the Prime Minister
who is uh going next
so Peter spoke yesterday during the uh
his heirs and successes according to law
so help me God
veteran Tory MP sir Peter bottomley was
a junior Minister uh under uh John Major
I do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and affirm that I will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty King Charles is Harriet Harman
obviously the mother of the house just
just long-serving labor MP former
Minister told an affectionate story
yesterday about how after she was sacked
she was invited to uh Buckingham Palace
for tea when nobody else wanted to speak
to her I swear by almighty God
back to
his majesty King Charles is as and
successors according to law so help me
God
so the Prime Minister there
leading the senior politicians from the
government
this is Penny Morden who presided over
that Ceremony this morning the new
leader of the House of Commons of course
was a candidate for the Tory leadership
and successes
according to law
and it looks like Wendy Morton the new
Chief whip I think
that's the new chief
said only a few days ago as Governor
Chief whip
I swear by
my faithful and bear true allegiance to
his majesty King Charles is as it says
as according to law that's so help me
God that's Aleister Jack the Scotland
secretary who we saw at the accession
ceremony this morning
taking part
I swear by almighty God that I will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
eventually King Charles his heirs and
successes according to law so help me
God
that is Chris Heaton Harris the new
Northern Ireland secretary who uh
that would be faithful about true
allegiance to his majesty King Charles
his heirs and successors according to
law
and that of course is secure star mother
labor leader
I do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and affirm that I will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty King Charles his heirs and
successors according to law
that's uh thank him Debonair who is the
shadow leader of the House of Commons
I swear by almighty God that I will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
message this is Sir Alan Campbell the
labor Chief witness according to law so
helping God
nutrition
this one
yeah
I do swear that I will be faithful and
be a true religious to his majesty can
Charles his hears and successors
according to Luke
in Blackford the Westminster leader of
the Scottish national party
is saying and he's killed again
to his majesty from Charles as a bears
and successors according to law
at state snps chief whip
who's coming next
I swear by almighty God I will be
faithful and bear truly
truly Majesty King Charles his heirs and
successors according to Lord
so help me God
and Sarah Davey lib Dem leader
who's a minister in the coalition
government
and that's the Wendy Chamberlain the lib
Dems Chief whip so it seems to be a
government business managers as well as
Party leaders who are early on in the
proceedings here I swear by almighty God
that I will be faithful it says Sir
Jeffrey Donaldson leader of the dup
Democratic unionist Party
okay
[Applause]
I swear I would like to go but I will be
grateful about True Religions to his
magazine cars his heirs and successes
according to laws so help
that's Liz Savile Roberts who is the
leader of Clyde comrie
both in Welsh as well as in English
poverty she often says a few words in
Welsh in the chamber usually at the
beginning of a question
there's several Roberts
I swear by Omega golf I will be faithful
and bear true of 18 students how to
speak King Charles this heirs and
successors according to law to help you
Lord
say we're on to the smaller parties now
that's the sdlp
his heirs and successors according to
law to help me God
so that's the new Deputy Prime Minister
and health secretary to raise coffee
Theresa May had a moving tribute
yesterday during the proceedings
think this is I think yes these are the
deputy speakers coming now
it's Majesty King Charles his areas and
successors according to law so healthy
God
so that's Dame Eleanor Lang
who's uh
senior Deputy speaker chairman of ways
and means this is Dame Rosie Winterton
of her that I would be faithful I'm a
labor Minister and labor Chief whip one
stage his majesty
MPS in the Commons swearing allegiance
to the new King King Charles III